go to your fridge right now go to your  fridge right now everyone has mayo in  their fridge right unless you look like  can't even have it for anything I want  in the comments what the expiration date  is of the Mayo in your fridge because  nine times out of ten when I go to use  my Mayo it is completely expired because  I use it so sparingly and it goes bad so  quick and I'm always like it's always a  game of like all right this Mayo's been  done a month because it has been done  two weeks as well actually I think a lot  of what you guys are saying is wrong  Mayo according to this tends to prevent  bacterial growth because it is made with  acids it has vinegar or lemon juice in  it Mayo actually has a very long shelf  life in the in the refrigerator